al grand
it solves so that's the the the company
the team
of cryptographers mathematicians
engineers so on that challenge the
blockchain trilemma
so let's break it down in terms of
achieving scalability
how do we achieve scalability in the
space of blockchain in the space of
cryptocurrency
okay so uh scalability security remember
and decentralization yes so that's what
they want what's the best way to
approach can we break it down let's
start with scalability
and think about how do we achieve it
well to achieve it
one at a time is perhaps
even security if nobody transacts nobody
loses money
so beta is secure but it's not scalable
so let me tell you i'm a cartographer
sorry so i try to
fight the bad guys and what
what you want is that a vessel ager that
we discussed before
uh cannot be tampered with so you must
think of it avetta
is a special link that nobody can erase
okay then
it has to be everybody should be able uh
to read and not to alter
the pages or the content of the pages
that's okay
but you know what that is actually easy
cryptographically
easy cryptographical means you can use
tools invented 50 years ago which
in cryptographic time is prehistory okay
we are
cavemen working around yes and solve
their problem
in cryptography land but you know but
there is really a fundamental problem
which is really
almost a social seems a political
problem is to say
who the hell chooses
or publishes the next page on villager
i mean that is really the challenge with
ledger
you can always add a page because more
and more transactions to be
written on there and somebody has to
assemble with
this transaction put them on a page and
under the next page
who is this somebody who chooses the
page and adds it on who can be trusted
to do it
exactly assume it is me for what i'm
being and not that i want to volunteer
for the job but
then i would have more power than any
absolute monarch in history
because i would have a tremendous power
to say these
are the transactions that the entire
world should see
and whatever i don't write this
transaction will never see
the light of day i mean no one had any
such a power industry
so it's very important to uh to do that
and that is the quintessential problem
in a blockchain
and uh people have thought about it to
say it's not me it's not you but
for instance in uh proof of work
what people say is to say okay it's not
me it's not you you know what it is
we make a very difficult we
invent a cryptographic puzzle very hard
to solve
the first one to solve that as the right
to add one page to the ledger
on behalf of everybody else and that's
now is
seems okay because you know sometimes i
solve a puzzle before you do sometimes
you solve
before i do or before somebody else
somebody else solves it
it's okay and presumably the effort you
put in
is somehow correlated with how much
trust
you should be given to add to the ledger
yeah so somehow you want to make sure
that you know you need to
work because you want to prevent you
want to make sure of vetno
you get one solution every 10 minutes
say like
in particular example of bitcoin so beta
is very rare but two pages are added at
the same time
because if i solve the puzzle at the
same time you do
you could happen that if it happens once
or twice we can survive
it but if it happens you know every
other page you know
it's a double page of when uh which of
the two is the real page it becomes a
problem
so that's why in bitcoin it is important
that to have
substantial amount of work so that no
many how many people try on earth
to solve a puzzle you have one solution
out of how many people are trying every
10 minutes so that you have
you distantiate these pages and you have
the time to propagate for the network
resolution
and the page attached to it and
therefore there is one page at a time
that is added
and they say well why don't we do that
we have a solution
well first of all a page
every 10 minutes is not fast enough it's
a question of scalability
and second of all to ensure that no
matter how many people
try you get the one page generator
minutes
one solution to the riddle every 10
minutes this means
that the riddle becomes very very hard
and to to have a chance to solve it
in within 10 minutes you must have such
an expensive
apparatus in terms of specialized
computers not one not two but thousand
and thousand of them
and they produce tons of heat okay these
they dissipate it like maniac
and you need to refrigerate them too and
so then now you have
air conditioning uh galore to add to the
thing
it becomes so expensive that fewer and
fewer
and fewer people can actually compete
in order to add to the page and the
problem becomes a so
some crucial veteran or
in in in bitcoin um
depending on which day of the week you
look at it you are going to have
two or three mining pools are really
the ones capable of controlling the
chain
so you're saying that's uh that's almost
like uh
at least a centralization right it
started being
decentralized and uh but the expenses
become
higher and higher and higher when
becomes higher and higher fewer and
fewer people can afford them
and then you know it becomes you know de
facto centralized right
yeah and in the different type of
approach
uh is instead for instance a delegated
proof of stake
which is also very easy to explain
uh essentially boils down to to say well
uh look at these 21 people say okay
don't they look honest yes they do in
fact
i believe if they're going to remain
honest for the foreseeable future so
when do we do ourselves a favor
let's entrust them to add the page
on behalf of all of us to the ledger
okay
okay but now we are going to say is this
centralized or decentralized well
21 is better than one what to say is
very little
so if you look at uh when people
rebelled to centralized power i don't
know the french
revolutions okay there was a monarch and
the nobles
yes were there 21 nobles no there were
thousands of them but were millions and
millions of
disempowered citizens so one is
centralized
21 is also centralized all right so
that's delegated proof of stake
delegate kind of like a representative
democracy i guess
yes which is good working great right
it's working great well it's better than
uh
right and uh but uh there's there's
problems
there are problems yeah and and so
um we were looking for a different uh
when
thinking about algonquin for a different
approach
and so we have a man approaching
veterinary is really really
decentralized
because essentially um
he works as follows so you have a bunch
of tokens right these are the tokens
uh that have equal power and you have to
say 10 billions of tokens
distributed from um to the entire world
and the owners each token
has a chance to add value equal
probability by
everybody else in fact actually if you
want
here is how it works so think about you
know
by some magic cryptographic process
which is not magic is mathematics but
think of it the magic assume that you
select a thousand tokens
and so sometimes a random okay and you
have a guarantee that the handle was
selected
and then this the owners of this 1000
tokens
somehow agree on the next page they all
sign it
and that is the next page okay
so it is clear that you know nobody has
the power but you know
uh once uh up uh in a while
one of your tokens is selected and you
are in charge of this
committee to select the next page but
this
goes around very quickly so and if you
look at this
the question really is that is not
really centralized
and because of what for for agreeing on
the same page it is important
that the 1000 tokens that you're
randomly selected
are in honest ends the majority of them
so which if the majority of the tokens
are in honest ends that is
essentially true because if the majority
of the tokens are in honest ends
if you select say 90 percent of the
people
are 90 percent of the tokens are in
honest hands
so can you randomly select a thousand in
this thousand you you find the 501
tokens in bad ends very very improbable
so basically uh when a large fraction of
people are honest then you can
use randomness as a powerful tool to get
decentralization so what does honesty
mean
and uh now we're into the social
side of things which is uh how do we
know that like the fraction the a large
fraction of
uh people or participating parties are
honest
that is a an excellent question so by
the way first of all we should
realize that the same thing is for every
other system when you look at proof for
work
you rely that the majority of the mining
power
is in honest hands yes when you look at
a delegated proof of stake
you realize that the majority of these
21 people are honest
what is the difference the difference is
veta
in these other systems you should to say
the whole economy
is secure if the majority of this
small piece of economy are honest
and that is a big question but instead
what
would in our grand in our approach we
say
the whole economy is secure if the
majority of economy is honest
in other words who can subvert all
ground is not a majority of a small
group
but is a majority of the token holders
had to conspire with each other
in order to think of a very economy for
which they own the majority of
yes that i think it is a bit harder to
like a destructive majority essentially
and you're also making me realize that
basically every system that we have in
the world today
assumes that the majority of
participants is honest
yes the only difference is the majority
of whom
and in in some cases the majority of a
club and in our case is the majority of
the whole system
the whole the whole system okay so
that's that's fast so
through that kind of
random sampling you can achieve
decentralization
you can achieve so the scalability
i understand and then the security that
you're
referring to basically the security
comes from the fact that
the sample selected would uh likely
include honest people
so it's very difficult to so by the way
the security as you
as you mentioned that you're referring
to is basically
security against dishonesty right or
manipulation or whatever
yes yes so essentially when what you're
going to
to do is to be following and say say
well silvio i understood what you're
saying
but somebody has to randomly select it
with tokens when i believe you so then
who does this random selection that's a
good point and
uh in uh in algorithm we do something a
little bit
unorthodox essentially is
the token choose themselves at random
and you say if you think about it
that seems to be a terrible idea because
if you want to say
choose yourself at random and whoever
chooses himself is a fuss and people
committee
you choose the page for for the rest of
us
and because if i'm a bad person i'm
going to select myself
over and over again because i want to be
part of the committee every single time
but that not so fast so what do we do
in algon what does it mean that i select
myself that each one of us
in the privacy of our own computer
actually a laptop
what you do is that you execute
your own individual lottery
and think about that you pull a lever
of a slot machine you can only pull the
lever once not
until you win not enough times until you
win and when you pull the lever
case one either you win in such a case
you have a winning ticket
or you lose you don't get any winning
ticket so
if you don't have a winning ticket you
can say anything you want about the next
page in village nobody pays attention
but
if you ever win a ticket people say oh
wow he's
one of the 1000 winning tickets we
better pay attention to what
he or she says and that's how it works
and
the lottery is a cryptographic lottery
which means that even if i am
an entire nation extremely powerful with
incredible computing powers i don't have
the ability to improve even minimally my
probability
of one am i talking with me the lottery
and
that's how it happens so everybody pulls
the lever
the 1000 random winners say oh here is
my winning
ticket and here is my opinion up or down
about the block
these are the ones that count and if you
think about it
while this is distributed because there
is in the case of argon there is a
10 billion tokens and you select a
thousand of them more distributed than
this
you cannot get and then why is this
you know scalable because what you have
to do
okay to do the lottery how long the
lottery takes
it takes actually one microsecond
whether you have one token or two tokens
or a billion tokens is always one
microsecond of computation
which is very fast we don't hit the
planet with a microsecond of computation
and finally why is this secure
because even if i were a very evil
and very very powerful individual i'm so
powerful that i can corrupt
anybody i want instantaneously in the
world
whomever i want to corrupt the people in
the committee
so that i can choose the page of
malaysia but i do have a problem
i do not know whom i should corrupt
should i corrupt this lady in shanghai
the sovereign guy in paris
because i don't know i should the
winners are random so i don't know whom
i should corrupt
but once the winner come forward and say
here is my winning ticket
and you propagate your winning ticket
across the network
together with your opinion about the
block now i know who they are
for sure i can corrupt all thousands of
them given to my
incredible powers but so what whatever
they said they already said and their
winning tickets and their opinions
are vaguely propagated across the
network and i do not have the power
no more than the us government or any
government has the power to put
back in the bottle a message virally
propagated by wikileaks
you